y llegamos directo hasta alemania para
hablar con nuestra enviada especial a la
reunión del g7 como lo estamos también
conversando con consultaba una economía
érick olavarría como avance esta cumbre
y cuáles han sido los acuerdos que se
han llegado hasta el momento como por
ejemplo más apoyo a ucrania para
combatir en el terreno a las tropas
rusas y también las nuevas sanciones a
rusia a erick a
si efectivamente regulo hoy sin duda la
noticia o el día por lo menos en lo que
corresponde a la mañana ha estado acá
parada primero por esa participación a
distancia por videoconferencia el
presidente de ucrania selenski frente a
esta cumbre de las siete naciones más
poderosas del mundo y luego esa
declaración de la presidencia alemana y
de todos los miembros del g7 apoyando a
ucrania diciéndole prometiéndole que le
van a apoyar hasta que termine esta
guerra baste el tiempo que sea necesario
para estar al lado de este país que
defiende sus fronteras su derecho
legítimo justamente a la imm bolivia la
inviolabilidad de su territorio ayuda a
militar económica ayuda humanitaria y
logística y también diplomática y esa
promesa de los miembros del g7 de volver
a imponer nuevas sanciones a rusia a
aislar a este país para que cada vez
tenga menos dinero para hacer la guerra
esas sanciones que mencionaban ustedes
justamente en el bloque económico y
también sanciones en contra de la
tecnología occidental que aún es
utilizada por las industrias de rusia en
general que lo que le pidió el
presidente excelencia 7 esta mañana y
que justamente esta declaración voy a
hacer como una respuesta bueno les
recordó la situación que se está
viviendo en el país sobre todo estos
bombardeos del domingo en contra de kiev
que muestran la gravedad de la guerra en
ese país como a diario antes era
bombardeada 15 veces por misiles rusos
al día durante el domingo esa cifra
aumentó a 62 y en general en estos
cuatro meses de guerra ha sido
bombardeada 3800 veces por misiles rusos
pero también el presidente pidió que se
den garantías de seguridad que es esto
que los países del g7 se comprometan a
respetar la integridad territorial de
este país pidió obviamente seguridad
alimentaria recordemos que hay muchos
granos de ucrania que están bloqueados
en el país no pueden salir es lo que
está generando además la crisis
alimentaria en todo el mundo la uno está
tratando de intentar sacar el trigo y
estos otros granos pero también el país
ha pedido al presidente ucraniano que se
les permita espacio para almacenar las
nuevas cosechas de trigo y de granos que
se van a producir también que se
intensifiquen las sanciones
dijo que él considera que una fecha
buena para el fin de la guerra es el fin
del año porque comienza el invierno y
eso va a ser muy difícil mantener las
tropas en pie eric además de estos
países del g7 hay países invitados entre
ellos uno latinoamericano argentina que
hace en estos países como invitados en
esta cumbre
si son países muy importantes raúl
países emergentes con gran territorio
con mucho potencial en cuanto a la
producción de energía y también en
cuanto a la capacidad de tener un gran
mercado y también son importantes porque
producen alimentos como argentina no que
es un gran productor de cereales
básicamente lo que quiere el g7 es que
estos países elijan el bando al que
quieren pertenecer pues sobre todo
sudafricano cierto y a la india son
países que comparten con rusia el grupo
de los brics son países que en general
tienen buenas relaciones también con
rusia entonces lo que quiere básicamente
el g7 es que se queden de un lado o del
otro y justamente eso va la línea lo que
dijo el canciller soltó esta mañana que
dijo que bueno que había que mostrar que
el mundo no era las potencias
occidentales desarrolladas y el rato
sino que no había que caer en la trampa
de luces que quiere crear una división
en el mundo